good old jr. what's going on man how are
you thanks for having me on thanks for
being here welcome
the traffic's lovely is it Huff what
part of the city you staying in au
Midtown downtown I'm staying I'm staying
in Long Island City wow they're new have
you in Manhattan it's crazy because I
think the tree-lighting screwed
everything up because it really is the
city is a nightmare for hotels right now
yeah I got it nice the are called the
Paper Factory
that's a hotel yeah is it like a little
boutique hotel
oh yeah it's cool I'm pretty good now
are you are you a you a guy who has
become like are you comfortable in any
kind of place or I became a primadonna
with accommodations or you kind of
stayed wherever they put you they put
you I am a little snobbish you are yeah
do you like your good four-star a
five-star hotel
yeah or at least a something with a
second room you're not gonna like a
suite yeah yeah Marriott suites are
Fairfield I don't care if it's Fairfield
suites yeah those are comfortable what
do you need the second room for to
spread out Sam I'm a big man I see I
have meetings right tech meetings and
entertainment you know right I know I'm
not there yet you like to have a second
rule you like it so far
a couch a couple extra chairs there you
go home I don't sit on my bed watch
television no you want a gentleman's
accommodation it makes sense but it's be
no people think we go what do you you
know you're not happy with where they
put you at say no you start to get like
a little greedy as you get older I've
done the same way you want good stuff
you weren't like that in the early days
you had to do a lot of very terrible
accommodations oh you got schnauzer how
was he when I was the elected driver of
the in territory days hauling the
wrestlers around I would because I
didn't make any money I would sleep on
the floor it's constant their bets
fred's until I saw they finally the
Dateline features all those black lights
and all the oh so I'm thinking oh my god
I was thus const in that for at least a
year the rows are $8 a night no kidding
I'm oh god I'm not God I'm not that old
eight bucks with their fleabags
two beds eight dollars to the rest of
fat for four I got the I got the s
constantly addressed Fred and I was the
channel changer so I was the remote
control what
you was that would you say 74 75 74 and
75 they didn't have remote no they get
up
Jimmy change the channel just a kid kid
kid black so you're trying to go to
sleep here's the good news there are
only like usually back three channels
that's true right right so it's like
even if even if their channel surfing
it's not gonna last more no 30 second
would you stay with who would typically
be in the room with you I wrote in a
with a guy named Danny Hodge and scanned
our Akbar do you know who they are Sam
they of course I don't know they are
yeah they're legends old-time guys Hodge
was a Jim was a three-time all-american
college wrestler oh you Oklahoma
University and was never never defeated
with two Olympics when the National
Building was boxing championship he's a
badass yeah so he was my he was the
riding shotgun I drove all the time and
Akbar rode in the back and so just
snicker that cigars but they were good
to me talking about saving money and not
making bad decisions on the road which I
still did some but they at least helped
me say you go there you get in trouble
so it's your call well I watch a
sergeant would you watch guys go out and
get wild and kind of screw things up
because they didn't know how to handle
the road they guys would get pissed with
the other guys for going out and going
to the hotel that they're staying in
where they're getting a rate and
probably plenty of nice little perks and
somebody would do something like they're
checking out or go into the next town
that they take a dump in a bed make the
bed the contest to see who could drop
the biggest saw logs in the in the beds
and make them put the victim it right
back up so I'm so much chicks
interesting clean and there's there's a
DNA you know when Jim when Jim was early
in his comedy days he traveled with a
couple comics that you see used to call
themselves because of things they would
do with their bodily fluids the load
warriors Oh Jim and Bob yeah yeah but
that's funny because you make the bed so
then the may just touch it somebody
what happen is then of course I got
turned in you know you're not gonna hey
I got a problem down here it's no big
deal you can't come in and fix it I'll
sleep in the [ __ ] I don't care but you
know that's where they were and so then
that killed the rate then this the
owners say no more wrestlers so all the
good rate all the late checkouts are
really early check-ins everything that
she were you needed the perks the Byway
gone
so they price it out so the wrestlers
aren't going to stay there anymore bingo
all right are they just violate their
civil rights and Bartel just no I refuse
not to serve you well you it was more
like because they probably figured look
we taking care of you guys could we like
you like I knew what guy worked for the
airline and he would always up here
fired because he would always upgrade
wrestlers to first-class really he loved
them yeah so these guys have booked
coach tickets and all of a sudden had
called him and he put him in first click
is he's just loved wrestling and he
loved the wrestlers so I imagine there's
a lot of perch like that from guys who
are fans did this guy one time work for
Continental yep wow that's one thing the
plot thickens you end up sitting in
first class gym a lot of times yeah yeah
I'll bet now do you ever yeah but my
trip was Newark to Seattle first-class
bulkhead sitting next to Jim Cornette
hates flying with a sincere disdain
who's that
he's a manager a great manager he was
the owner of territory Smoky Mountain
wrestling hall of fame level okay he's a
he's like the southern version of Paul
Heyman yeah he also he's very outspoken
and he curses a lot okay yeah why is he
hateful why is he afraid of it yes okay
so you had to sit with him yeah so he
has this ritual but with his meds no so
he takes some certain intervals so he
takes his meds and he's passing out on
the prewar and he's in his seat and the
lady says she's gonna wake him up see
what's for coffee I don't know no he
don't know wake him up he said he didn't
like to fly okay
well it's all good we get on the runway
the tarmac at our man and the tarmac guy
says well I want to appreciate air
traffic control today we're now only
17th in line for takeoff
so now all this meds got backed it up
see he comes down he wakes up somewhere
like over Minnesota or something right
because here years a year taking off 45
minutes
now or afterthought sure yeah so uh he's
uh he says he's freaking out now cuz we
got two hours to go and he gonna work he
can't drug up to war he can't no he says
you got to talk to him talk to me go
talk to him okay I'll talk to you she
said something so now when somebody
tells somebody's a communicator to talk
it's not as easy to sound right what he
won't talk about yet he said I don't
care to talk saying or you know saying I
surely so now I'm thinking this was an
appropriate song for two men to sing to
each other in the first-class bucket
without you know racing unfair and
unresolved issues he says I saw our sort
of saying I said I've caught you
knocking at my cellar door [ __ ] so and
everybody looked at least you guys a
Siegfried and Roy there no that's too
noticeable guys like there's going to be
a fan up there that's think what is
going on between jr. and Jim Cornette
people really thought you guys didn't
like each other oh yeah that's what we
warned them to thank us I was the fan
favorite baby face like announcer
technical standing for right and
goodness in essence and he was the
cheating villainous gain an unfair
advantage
Malby manager and you have that the book
by the way Jim is promoting a book is
called slobberknocker at my night of my
life and wrestling it's out now and
tonight Jim is gonna be signing if
you're here on the East Coast in New
York New Jersey he's signing
slobberknocker at bookends in Ridgewood
which is a great independent bookstore
even if it's raining there's plenty of
room to line up inside you're not gonna
be standing outside he's performing in
one-man show ringside at the last Boston
Oh December 16th Mick Foley's been doing
stand-up or you do you by the way get
tickets for that now because around the
holidays that will probably go very fast
lap Boston's a great club up there in
Boston is it kind of stand-up or is it
all pure stories or is it kind of mixed
I'm not really a stand-up Jim I'm not in
your league I'm a storyteller but a lot
of my stories are descanse in humor okay
and they're this funny stuff that's
happened to me all right I did or
fit in and so and the stories the
counting honor to the wrestling fans
their stories about people that are
famous right that they they know in
their wrestling world it might not
resonate with you as much as with Sam
out sure cuz I don't know the people but
you know what [ __ ] in the bed and
then putting the big that that's a story
home run for anybody I think it's gonna
work out good and the we got a lot of
stories in slobberknocker because I did
have I got a I was supposed to be in the
wrestling business man they didn't want
a little fat guy with a southern accent
getting in a rational cuz I didn't want
to be a wrestler
I didn't know what I wanted to be I was
intrigued by the business and it's
worked I thought a three-month gig would
be three months I go back to college and
graduate that three month gigs lasts
over 40 years so Slough you've been 40
years yeah 74 she ran away with the
circus and never came home so my dad
said yeah yeah my boy ran away the
circus and by god he's never coming home
I actually thought of you Norton because
reading slobberknocker and I felt like
the chapter that would resonate most
with Norton was probably the chapter
that you were in the car with Vince
McMahon early on in the WWF days because
Jim gets into Vince's love for driving
fast yes singing along to ac/dc
oh and flatulence so good he drops
gassers
protein of course though we're like a
Cadillac rental car beckons before the
plane came along we're making it trips
by land and a lot of the guys that
option they would bail on Vince because
either willing to talk business all the
time or they wanted to avoid his
flatulence and so me being the new guy
in 93 soon thereafter I think the second
one came back the second time that I got
designate arrive events now I was also
getting in charge of talent relations
and a talent roster
and booking the house shows it sounded
you know negotiating contracts so I
needed time with but boy I wasn't
prepared for the farting no windows he
showed this insult it it broke the ice
in a very crude way sophomore guy get
Gai way that he's the chairman of the
company he's the most powerful man in
the world and what you do for a living
you by God better pay attention and try
to learn something and so those were
like Wilk lat rolling classrooms they
were stinky what year did you start with
him 93 oh that was that what were you
doing before that what wrestling
nineteen years before that in the
territories oh and then I went to work
for Ted Turner I did WCW in Atlanta on
TBS and their favorite views and things
of that nature so I was I was an
overnight sensation Jim it took me 19
years to make it to the WWE and I think
I said I've been working for years of
the Indies I can't get a tryout I said
well I worked 19 years making 25 to 40
dollars a day and I got my tryout and I
ran with it did you want to do did you
want to be with Vince a lot longer than
that and it was just hard to get in yeah
but uh yeah here's guys won't admit this
because they're we live in a defiant
society but shoot it the ultimate goal
for any wrestler is to get into WV at
some point right if you're a football
player and you're gonna play for money
don't you want to play in the NFL right
exactly
sorry that's kind of where you are here
and it's not knocking all these little
emotions they just don't have the assets
the infrastructure and resources at WS
to make you a bigger star than you ever
dreamed well plus not only did you have
to go 19 years before you get to WWE but
before you became kind of the household
name jr. that everybody knows you'd
already been fired by them twice right
so you don't even fired and come back
you kind of have gone through you you
you you lived through just about every
excuse that somebody could come to you
and explain to you why it's not working
for them yeah I I tell the talents take
it from me give the company no reason to
not want to do business with you and you
know there are some of those things are
really basic guys no different than you
guys have you got to get working on time
yeah you got a certain schedule to keep
you're obligated to do that and and
therefore you get paid or you get paid
for all for keeping your obligations
well I was hard to manage and I was
really outspoken I had a stronger
philosophy about my way or the feeling
my way the highways heal and I didn't
have very much patience to come from
and so I think he just got tired of my
BS you were difficult
I was I was and I was really I love the
product and I love being there maybe too
much what was something you were
difficult about that you look back I
should have been a little easier by that
Oh probably in general creative
direction I thought that fro resting is
an entertainment entity I get that it's
not a sport because the outcomes were
predetermined said to say I told you
folks it's to believe I'll just raise
your Christmas you know it's just uh I
just didn't like the creative direction
and I wasn't even here's the one here's
the problem it's okay not to like it but
by god that's what the boss wants you're
obligated to try to make it work sure is
that the mistake that a lot of people
make that they think like oh well I have
the best idea so I'm gonna go in and
we're gonna do my ideas and you're like
it's it's not your sandbox man big bingo
is not their sandbox and that's what no
if you have if you give this an idea or
a writing guy or somebody an idea that
works and you kind of build a little bit
of a resume that's a pretty good ideas
for example stone coal was red-hot and
he designed his own t-shirts because he
liked doing it and they sold rights they
sold and so consequently when Steve
would come to events for the idea he'd
just Vincent just bless it and fit right
on the pricing around through because he
knew it would sell and Steven if its
audience but when you were in charge of
hiring people you kind of had a little
bit of carte blanche to hire people it
didn't share or no yes how did you end
up with that kind of whatever I with
that kind of power where you'd say Vince
this is the new guy I just hired he's
the one who's coming in I gave him my
third Warren I think it was just as I
said already about some other stuff I
think it was the fact that I got a few
wins
I had a few son good signings I did well
on the air for him and then he one of
the talent Department restructured I did
that and started the developmental
programs which now it's morphed into the
Performance Center right so and then we
had some we have some great classes you
know we had we had one class that was
headlined by
Shelton Benjamin he was the best athlete
the group was about to mention Shelton
Brock I would have gotten Rock without
Shelton and of course Gerry Briscoe
John Cena Dave Batista and Randy Orton
so that's all one class one class one
developmental classes Brock Lesnar
this guy Shelton Benjamin John Cena
Randy Orton and Batista that's
incredible
yeah whoo you're now looking at not only
is like the biggest names in wrestling
but you got a movie star in there you
got a UFC star you know I also sign the
rock also son Kurt Angle among another
Edge and Christian so if you grab
stunning Steve Austin I have actually
did yeah so those guys all love you well
I don't know if they love me I think
they hope they respect me Jim I do but a
lot of them do when my wife got killed
in March the first phone calls and the
Texas were from my little rock court
guys Austin rock of course Vince and you
know they were so good that the business
deal was if you need anything a doctor
whatever Mark Cuban said I'll fly a
doctor in a neurologist to examine your
wife on one of my planes and I haven't
there tomorrow maybe but she was at that
point was wasn't just what gonna happen
so but all those guys man you find out
who your buddies are when you're some of
the kitchen and nuts and you go out to
your knees she was I she was sick for a
long time no she was sick at all she was
riding home or vessel from the gym a guy
ran over a hill and didn't see her he
said and oh he ran over the top over oh
yeah kill her
he was in a 2000 Mary Marquis and man he
car and that Robert returning to go to
my house is for her bike caught on fire
so it's still charred so I Drive by the
damn thing every day to go home
which is almost prompted me to want to
move but I don't think I'll bail on it
but I'm not look or do you look I look
every time yeah every damn time and I
can't help right and I generally say
something to her you didn't end up going
out coming in do you feel like moving
would be abandoning that maybe yeah I'm
not like where I live you know you know
when you get to be in my stage of life I
got real good gigs of WV access TV in
the podcast and so forth but more I like
my neighbors and I like my doctors there
in the town you know
you got you know we don't like to think
about that [ __ ] you know we're old
you're getting old now you're you gotta
be aware of your mortality sure and I
want to be around my doctor so I have my
cell phone and I can call any time and
say you know can I come see or whatever
do you have kids I do have two daughters
okay once the licensed physician
assistant and the other is a sales
manager for a publishing company do you
think that now do you want to just not
ever remarry or how like you dying to
think about that at this point or do you
like some day maybe I have to or I want
to I don't know I I like companionship
but I don't want to get into the you
know old dude trying to be young the
dating game she find a nice nineteen
year old know how that would work out
poorly her name is like so annoying this
is sugar sugar yeah my kids my
granddaughter here she's just a little
older younger
she's 14 your night your teens yeah I
think I think he could work well how did
you mean how did you become buddies with
Mark Cuban well he hired me they when
when Maranello came to WWE and I think
you want to smack down at that time they
access this meeting a play-by-play guy
to go with Josh Barnett and on their
show so they approached AUSA ready to go
I was free agent and I signed a two-year
deal with them and that two years will
be up the end of this month
and we'll start another one-year deal
you can't get another deal though one
year dude yeah let's go do one year time
that's the same deal same logic hey I'm
65 years old I feel good I'm healthy
Duncan would you know lose all the
weight I get it but I don't smoke
anymore and I'm obsessively drinking I'm
drinking I only had three Moscow heels
all day yesterday that's not bad I
thought that was pretty good
what do you like doing this not rashly
that's it that's such a certain tone
world that's such like an aggressive
like kind of alpha world what do you
enjoy doing that has nothing to do with
that tantric sex
what the hell that is we like deny
orgasms or whatever and like sting is
the one who's left ours all pass
yeah enough a raw deal for me to screw
for hours anyway I don't think I need to
get out of breath that long we're only
eight I think I was a football freak I
like sports all sports
I go to the Thunder games I cease to
take a little Oklahoma football I'm
going to the Rose Bowl support my team
against Georgia
so I football somebody there and they
they've accepted me as family
I'm on the sideline for every game oh
you are access to the locker rooms or
wherever I want to go and they're just
so wonderful there for me and I now try
to cific a modem on social media I
donate I'll give money I'm a donor but
they this family of those guys so
football's my deal and having them I
play wrestling fans yeah well you know
what you find out is that the kids are
fans of mine but their dads are bigger
fans of mine because their dads are
likely in an age where we're rocking and
rolling on money nights where we get
some quarter hours would be money not
football right now these ratings were
scary and the audience side of the
audience you know there were nights that
we had three times as many viewers as
they as money nights drawn out when
you're doing commentary for like an
audience that's that big do you realize
as you're doing it how many people are
listening or is that kind of in
hindsight goddamn that was a lot of
people huh no at hindsight yes I was
that's the one yes wow that's a lot of
folks it's the same as going into right
after on the first week of January I'm
gonna go in the studio about a few hours
after Russell Kingdom mm-hmm on the
fourth of January in the Tokyo Dome I'm
gonna voiceover I would promise you
you'll get the same call as you would if
I were there and maybe even better
because I don't have any distractions
how was the so you called your first
match for WWE in years in March and I
mean at WrestleMania and this was really
quickly after your wife had passed and
that was the dad's the big match of the
night that was Undertaker vs. Roman
reigns how do you feel about you
your performance looking back on it I've
never heard it back mm-hmm I'm kind of
kind of a resistant at listening to my
own work I always feel like I'd be
better I'm cognizant of my acquired
speech and pediments because the
paralysis of my face of my mouth Bell's
palsy yeah yeah three of them so I hear
that you know you're insecure about it
oh yeah yeah this is crazy insecure so I
don't listen to it very much
I get wonderful confidence on
slobberknocker audio book
that's right listen to the hardest thing
I've ever done in my entire life
because my wife has just been dead a
while and I got to read about meeting
her right well I was very emotional man
I'm telling you it's very emotional and
it was in the days it has been another
generation I'd have gone out and smoked
a bone yeah been late lately I'd fire
going out and have a shot of crown but I
walked it off and tried to finish it but
it was hard man so I I don't even have
the balls to listen to it and the Bell's
palsy you said you've had three of them
is is each event considered how does
that how is that phrased or worried I
don't know much about it it you know and
neurologists don't know much about
either Jail they say we have no cause
and there's no cure so when you get
something like they say Jesus are you
sure you don't know what causes it well
we it may be viral but most of us think
it's stress-related and does it pass
though it goes away or if it generally
goes away in a matter of months mine
I've got symmetry back but I still can't
smile can show my teeth and you know you
people all time they don't know said
come on Jerry it was a big smile I'd
like to tell but you know you'll see me
of the one of the distinguished
sufferers have you been getting it your
whole life no when did it start 90 see
I'll go to 93 it happened on January
Super Bowl Sunday in 94 what were you
doing and how did you know by the way
that's that's seven months after you
start with us
that's a terrible time right and
tv-friendly world yes I already got the
chair face which is a fat ass southern
accent
I gotta get around I got I gotta have
something I don't have a smile so you
woke up and you just had it I thought I
had a stroke
yeah and because it's same symptoms I
couldn't blink one eye I ringing in my
ear migraine headache my face on one
side it dropped and so I went to a
doctor when there's a minor emergency
clinics was my wife who would only been
married since October this is January
she's like I married that oh my god so I
stopped father's eyes like every day I'm
sorry honey
cuz I know what's gonna do sure and the
I went to a doctor and he says well I
think you have Lyme disease he guessed
and so I finally went when she got home
I went to the neurologist next day and
it was Bell's palsy and there's just no
cure if you catch it the first of that
day one I was going from Oklahoma City
to Carolinas went on to be smackdown and
I had an attack on the plane the last
one and I got there and I hit the ground
running a coma
I had my text my doctor in the in the
home he called him a prescription for
prednisone
pregnancy on prednisone steroids or
cordilla steroid it's what Jerry Lewis
was taken when he looked like a blimp
boy yes was head up the Michelin guy
yeah so that was kind of how that worked
and I you take a pill immediately yeah
you take you take them immediately and
you know it will help curb its Fripp's
the spread 'no sand severity of it and
so i I totaled WAV what's happening I
should catch the next plane home go see
your doctor so that was it all right and
I was pretty much done after that I I
don't know if this is there if it is
stress doing live TV in that world might
not be the best place to come back your
stress yeah no I wouldn't think so yeah
I wouldn't think so
there's also I mean and you're talking
about it in the book do you get over the
insecurities quickly because right so
you start and you start as the
commentator on WrestleMania you start in
the highest place you could possibly
start you then within months you're just
kind of over in a corner doing
international shows you're not you don't
on TV anymore
then you get fired after that then you
come back and there's you know come back
but then you're fired again and start
like once once it happens the first time
that you're like okay I just want
from WrestleMania to lowest man on the
totem pole I don't know what I did wrong
maybe it's my performance maybe I'm not
good do you get over that insecurity
once you get through it the first time
yeah you can you can in this abyss of
battle it's a fight yeah and all we all
of us performers are paranoid to some
degree aren't we sure yeah that's yeah
because as soon as you give a bad
performance or as soon as someone tells
you you stink or you're not good it
validates what you really think
well [ __ ] the right like the good stuff
doesn't mean anything it's the one guy
going you stink yuck he knows they're
all wrong right knows and they're all
gonna figure out what he knows yeah he's
gonna convince them they're all gonna go
oh my god we've all been done yeah but
you're like Billy Martin getting fired
coming back I I just realized it your
and your question saying that you can't
get over it but you got to apply
yourself and not be afraid to change and
I have been doing the same thing I had a
lot of autonomy in WCW I was a VP there
it was a almost a leaderless division
before Eric got that job and it's just a
miss mismanagement of Three Stooges it
would be better so just bad but that
means when you sit down you put the
headset on you do whatever you want
basically yeah I didn't want a producer
I want you to count me in and count me
out right and leave me alone and if I
don't do well replace me right I gotta
be able to express what you brought me
here to do and so down there that was
kind of how they treated me all right
they count me in count me out and give
you little things that are down there
but not massive direction mm-hmm
if I give it a name wrong and you his
name is Smith not Jones or whatever so I
got corrected I think I just said Smith
uh I was gonna those right and that's
fine yeah so but I I had to change
because in WWE there's more massive
direction yeah yeah it's a big-time
television operation did you get
direction that you didn't like in the
moment and have to do it sometimes yeah
but see it's all your ad libbing only
I'm gonna fly in Vince's on the other
end sometimes and he he had ideas and I
didn't sometimes I didn't connect with
me but I used to redefine or resistant I
finally said sorted I'm gonna do that
line as best I can because apparently he
has a reason for it
now we'll tell you one story real quick
he said he
somebody say something on the air and I
ignored it and we're almost in the break
I'm going to the break so I say it
saying Nord it was the break so he down
during a break they are yes sir
only you know I couldn't hear this I'm
glad you didn't say what I told you to
say because it's stupid
remember what it was no it's not some
point about something but it it was
contradictory to where we were bowing
but where we were blowing was the
direction at one time and things changed
so frequently he'd forgot that we've
made that change and that line was
applicable any longer that's so you you
basically saved you you saved the
mistake from happening I tried to yeah
but I thought well it's you know he'd
forgotten and he he he said I'd you know
you did right
oh so you know where it's going so you
can kind of announce accordingly you all
notices all announcers have always
should know a general direction right
and look it's not chemistry here if you
figure it out come on so I the int but
the other side that is that's about all
I want to know I didn't know MIT folios
getting thrown off the top of the cell
that was dumb you weren't in the script
I've never seen a script I've got a
format Samian formats right yep
but it's not good it's not got intel on
it no right no break down to the show
here's what we're doing here's how long
it's gonna take Baba but it's never like
here's the here's the dialogue of what
you say are you afraid of running out of
stuff to say when you're just announcing
like you have to just you have to fill
that space and do they tell you when you
like how do you know when to talk and
want to just kind of let the action just
happen
feel feel you just feel it out yeah yeah
it's like you know it's like doing
comedy the wrestling is a lot like doing
comedy and as much as that a great
comedian has timing and he says
something funny and he hears the laugh
and he doesn't start his next joke until
the laughter subsides
your son's Berg right you got a pause
and let it let it happen yeah chill
don't cure your pop right so same thing
and wrestling guys do things you know
such an extent in today's market one of
my [ __ ] about it is they work too
fast and they don't let the audience a
process now they're out to me is but
junior year anova stirred
so just gonna take you longer to process
my stuff of course you really don't know
that much about the business yeah right
okay so but I'm just telling you yes I
said I give me example a great comedian
is going to dis audience laughs that's
what he's there for
laughs he wants to hear it because it's
good for him it's good for the others to
hear and then you start your second joke
or whatever so you taught your segue
into something else sure but it's
subside I've processed your humor I
laughed I reacted and I'll give me
another one you have to kind of
understand the ebb and flow of it not
and not just jump in and panic when
there's a moment of action and just feel
like you have to talk over I do the
access shows on Friday nights
you see HDNet and there's their one-hour
shows sometimes we have one match on one
hour and they say we don't want you to
plug what's coming up next
don't mention what's coming up next week
there's no paper used to plug there's no
sponsors to talk about there's no social
media to engage what's trending nothing
so we want you to call the match exactly
we see on the screen in the best
athletic presentation that you can today
want you calling moves the strategy yeah
that's the problem see the moves are
separate from the strategy mm-hmm and
the game plan right so if if you'd hit
me with a chop block and and I go down
hold my knee is the story the chop block
or the damage you did to my knee right
in my view it's the damage you did to my
knees because everybody can see it's a
chop block
but now announcers talk about the what
think we can see so they don't give me
anything extra sometimes and that's not
not good here you guys got it at all
Peter to the mind right television kind
of helps you out there right because
it's people are seeing it and something
but yeah but my anyway it might hurt too
because people might like you just said
describe the wrong thing too much
because they think that you could see
everything so they spend too much time
and avoid other things that you can't
see that you might know or necessary to
talk about we're supposed to be telling
the story right bringing people to the
place where they're supposed to be at
almost like I I feel like a good
commentator creates the lens through
which you should be looking at this
thing you just saw exactly right yes sir
and
gotta be have you had to like I'm sure
that the some matches are amazing and
exciting to watch and it's genuine your
enthusiasm and then it's got to be
moments where you've watched something
one like oh yeah this [ __ ] yeah it's so
of course of course you have and the
lower budget promotions I work for
sometimes had that oh you know the guy
said he's got a truck driver tan and and
a big old beer belly and he's Russell's
part-time he's there to put the other
guy over and it's like oh geez so in the
old adage was you got to make the
opponent that's losing has some
credibility or the guy that goes over
and wins beats nobody right so how do
you do that selectively creatively and
you got to find something that one
little thing to hang your hat on the
guy's got a big boat beer belly but he's
may have big shoulders there's a power
ass little shoulders
you see I take the try to take your eye
off his fat ass gut and there's all
those things gonna work out the gym to
get big arms I mean you got to work it
you know Dwayne Reed you want big arms
right right yeah but some of the guys
are just like yeah but I'm gonna eat
whatever I want and get big as a house I
still have the arms though you see these
arms I got my I still got my job to do X
station have any of the guys I'm a
rampage Jackson one time get pissed off
at Joe Rogan cuz Rogan had said
something about I forget he said
something about him and a match that he
didn't like so he kind of caught have
you had guys do that where you they
don't like something you've said about
it they've carried it I wrote a story in
my book about confrontation I had at the
WWE TV studios for 120 Hamilton with
Randy Savage
who's getting ready to beat my ass until
Gorilla Monsoon intervene I feel like
Larry King here well the brawl was by
Simon & Schuster all these names are
they were right happy now oh I booked
him to do some interviews I was
producing interviews and I've been stood
make sure the most markets were not
ringing live events we have to start
power those introduced segments I said
can I use Randy say absolutely should
use Randy good good thinking jr. thanks
so I've gotta do some interviews and
then some of the boys got in her skin
and you know riled him up and made him
think that I was doing it as a rib and I
was trying to make a fool of him and how
that could happen but that's the but
they got him stirred up did they do that
just because it's fun to get Randy yeah
hell yeah that's that guy's asking hey
what'd you get for Wrestlemania oh I
made uh hundred grand hundred grand
that's it I what the hell is that son of
a [ __ ] up and so they lie so I had a
guy one time come to my rooms do that my
office of TV and said you won't talk
about pay off somewhere well I said how
do you how do you know you're screwed
well what do you base it on some
forensic DNA test account II know uh
so-and-so told me oh okay all right
suppose there and I said they get me so
and through this first thing I don't
throw him in the bus go get him he got
it wrong okay City on it did you tell
him you made X at WrestleMania where it
was he started laughing and I he saw
everybody else was laughing I was just a
rib so so you lied to him to get him
pissed off so he'd come here and
confront me that I screwed he must fail
so how funny is it now how funny is it
now so that kind of nip that in the bud
but the saddest thing was he was he
thought I'd screwed him around I was it
but he grabbed me by my shirt it pushed
against the wall watch him right yeah he
rotted that that you know you know snap
into a slim jim boys right and so and
then monsoon because mom said we're
doing voice-overs I just go into the
ticket to go the bathroom so in Masan
went outside to have smokes when he came
back I wasn't there anyone looking for
me there he was so but Monson said like
three words the savage let me go and and
you know Connor told him in the voice
terms he's giving you exposure that you
would not get your on television he's
putting you on television Randy no sorry
no well my mistake my bad did you like
Randy I liked his work but I didn't like
working with him I he Randy would there
I never liked a lot of guys that say
they know Randy I wonder if they really
did he's very
closed very very almost paranoid
sometimes seem to me insecure and he's a
hell of a hand god almighty's great
wrestler great character but he just
didn't trust trust was a big issue to
him difficult guy oh yeah challenging
I don't know if this was a guy you were
talking about nine it's not really
throwing anybody under the bus cuz he
said it in an interview but Scott Hall I
was doing an interview with him and he
said that that's exactly what he used to
do he used to walk around and talk about
his payoffs and just just do it like
really loud around everybody just to
watch him walk get pissed off and just
like make up numbers walk through locker
room at some times the checks are coming
to TV the guys get their checks not a
good idea because they could hide over
there wise not good so you know Scott
Duluth kind of gather what the locker
says heads checking his hand right the
best the easiest 100 grand I ever eight
minutes of work $100,000 it pays to be
the bad guy so much buzz you know her
give me a her up how did you survive in
that role because you talk about like
you're the head of talent relations for
a while and that not only means hiring
people that means figuring out the
payoffs because that's the way pro
wrestling works WWE works is that they
get their their the money that is
brought into the venue for tickets and
and all that and then also pay-per-views
if it's on pay-per-view and then Jim
Ross sits there with a with a pad in the
paper I mean Patton a pencil
discretionary yeah and he figures out
who gets what percentage of this Wow
okay and so people are gonna get pissed
I know it's funny from you if they're
not the I made all the payoffs on on a
censored for everything but the paper
geez and the paper geez I would work up
the pace sheets then I would meet with
Vince and we'd go over them line by line
talent by talent I looked at the whole
thing but just the whole nine yards and
I always did it in pencil and that way
he's easier to change and he's always
changed things for that's his
prerogative I expected to do I learn
from those changes
so but it's discretionary so you there
but there's precedent for the the the
amount of money we had to pay and the
productivity the event where you were on
a car they were precedent to figure all
these moving pieces out so what is that
full remember oh we're a family I don't
know anything he looks like he's doing
him a grand well I was saying to not
Gran's know he's making too much money
they never had that that didn't happen
so you want your talents like all the
men they can but it's still
discretionary so it's always gonna be
debatable did you have to fire people or
is that always yes I did you did yeah
and here's the thing there's a misnomer
on that deal
I hired a lot of people on you know
Vince I don't know that this new Brock
Lesnar was till we introduced him I've
been recruiting Brock letters with Jerry
Brisco a year he was one of the greatest
heavyweights and incidentally wrestling
yeah and yes we know the USC badass and
he's a helping hand there now so this
let me hire a lot of people of course I
had it there my guys so they screwed up
didn't pan out there's another one on
the checkoff jeredy missed on that one
mr. no but the well exiting out the door
they hit when they got on the main
roster and they got into the for the
procedures of creative then I did not
never fire anybody without any consult
from Vince in other words he was gonna
say with jr. we don't have anything for
Sam anymore right we've got several
ideas he really hope he doesn't say that
we Scott would say a nice guy you know
but he's you gonna let him go well what
do you want to do this well we want to
do this angle play this out and then
here so then here I would get thief oh
man sir you'd sometimes know a month in
advance like this is coming at the end
of this angle crook but he wouldn't know
the performer would know until no but
see the day one yeah and then we let him
go and I would let him go and then they
were to get some sort of you know what's
the call record Severin Severin Thank
You senator thank you very much yeah
severence
and there was never fun but now when you
see wrestlers they're bitching and
disgruntled about jr. did this JR fire
Jade he fired me well they'd understand
I didn't create the reason to fire you
I didn't even wanna fire you I don't
like firing people but it's part of the
job sure
give him this news give him this news he
got a bonus give him this news you got
this and that's some news and it's not
good news sometimes good sometimes bad
there you go it's very true that Rhonda
is going to uh WWE Rhonda Rousey they've
been talking about that for a while I
think it's inevitable I really do I
think it's inevitable that she will do
something she's got the great
personality showbiz personality she's
got box-office sizzle she has sold paper
views there will be people that have
bought her USC pay-per-views that will
go to the WWE Network to our
pay-per-view to watch her at receive a
Wrestlemania because she has a track
record of chef's customer base she has a
fan base the question is I believe that
those MMA fans that loved her will
follow her for her first major event in
WWE that is my take on it so I think
it's inevitable so you think it's
inevitable she goes there yeah she also
loves wrestling I mean Rowdy Roddy Piper
was her it was it was an idol of hers
and she's a mainstream star - right so
it's not just the MMA fans Oliver's
people that are just curious at this
sheezus article that is Ronda Rousey
same as and I think some day Conor
McGregor will be do WWV you know what it
wouldn't surprise me if he did
considering the money right now the
amount of money he could probably get
has she been training in wrestling I
heard she has been training
she has been I think Nattie Neidhart has
been doing a little a tutoring of her
natty restaurant at E Stu Hart's
granddaughter one of my favorites but
she's ron is a group cool lady
yes she's good man I like her and I big
fan of her stuff and I and she's you
know we signed they signed one of her
her buddies Shayna Baszler
yeah and she was in the finals the myun
tournament that WWE had I worked with
Lita so that MMA influence is kind of
seeping in a little bit because they
have good mat skills and what they do is
so logical they're not looking to the
next spot or the next move they're
actually wrestling and do you think is
there any timeframe on her because she's
been out it's been a while since she
lost I saw I saw some video nur a few
days ago and she looked awesome she did
so I think she's diligent what she's
doing and I think she's also that
athlete and in her that she didn't want
to look bad the young female Hollywood
feel but also a great athlete she's
gonna say I want to stay in shape
because she's not the kind of person
you'll say oh look we're on to the
rulers of go right
yeah she's 230 I also think MMA has
changed the way people look at what a
fight is supposed to look like I think
that's why I like it's all kind of
seeped into the world of pro wrestling
because like kicks are much bigger now
submissions are a much bigger deal now
you know choke outs in in the early days
of my career the wrestling hierarchy
would never allow a star fan favorite a
babyface to lose by submission it's a
bad message to the kids that you quit
because it was it was totally
unrealistic made no sense
sure so now anybody can lose by
submission at any time because it is a
proven finish sure I'd like to ask you
it's pretty yes proving that like really
you know a very tough men will submit
you know so there's no there's no
disgrace in and I think what's helped
wrestling - I like the crossover back
and forth because guys like Brock who
people guy he's a wrestler you know he
was an animal in MMA he was a very very
tough guy and he beat some really tough
guys and even though CM Punk
lost to mickey Gaul he still he still
came out and is very dedicated
absolutely people even MMA fans have a
lot of respect for him you know sorry
Sam yeah you had a big deep breath there
and I was going I want to say that I
really admire Phil Brooks CM punk for
what he put his body through the weight
weight cut you know every lifestyle
changes and to the degree of a fighting
training fighter yeah and to go into a
area where he's gonna have a huge
microscope on him with where people most
a lot of the MMA people are wanting him
to get his ass whipped
yeah 37 years old fighting a much
younger guy jujitsu brown belt you know
yeah it was a really ballsy decision to
fight again till he still I don't doubt
it a bit and in I think he's just he's
gotta get out of the system and I he's
got any heel do well in whatever he does
I've missed him in wrestling because
he's goddamn entertaining if he wanted
to go back hoodie oh yeah I think so you
know I'm not making done for the boss
but or anybody a trip relating those
guys but if this if the pavement was
back smooth and there was communication
that's all viable on
upfront communication by everybody
involved I don't see any reason why I
couldn't come back he's a guy who's like
a lot of guys are able just to forgive
and forgetting all right whatever we had
that thing now you come back he's one of
those guys
absolutely we did that I saw that when
we tried to bring back the ultimate
warrior in the mid 90s and we had to go
to Phoenix to talk to him and that was a
lot going to a more peaceful June Jones
compound he's also the type to fire you
and then also write the foreword to your
book right yeah and I you know I did
that by text because he's busy and he
always answers me on text messages he
and I we communicate a lot that way a
lot of topics and as I said we're
getting ready to try to homestretch
trying to finish this books been
challenging since Jen's gone I could
give him a mind right and I'm trying I
said would you be interested in writing
the foreword and I promise you in five
minutes I'd be honored
just let to let this assistant know what
the due date is he said consider it done
and so it's same thing I did the same
thing Austin in Austin wrote the
backward they say I think I said
backward or whatever it is and I have
coach Bob Stoops write something Mark
Cuban wrote something Billy Gibbons easy
top rope so how nice and so it was a
good Rock of course